My name's Laurence Scott
and in my humble opinion,
I think that social media
is changing the ways
both in which we experience
the emotions of other people
and how we express
our emotions publicly.
I think the main thing you have
to think about in social media
is that our emotions
are a valuable resource.
So it behoves the people who are
designing social media networks -
such as Twitter, Facebook -
to make our emotions
as clearly obvious
and evident to others as possible.
So you may have noticed on Facebook,
one of the first questions
you're greeted with is,
"What's on your mind?"
Couple of years ago I noticed
sort of a comedy of errors
that's brewing in our emotional
landscape with social media.
So in the same year, Facebook finally
rolled out its six reaction features.
So instead of just simply liking
things that your friends have posted,
you could add the heart
or the sad face or the angry face.
Mark Zuckerberg at the time said,
"What people want
to do is express empathy."
But this empathy was again channelled
into a discrete set of emotions
that weren't limitless or boundless.
Now why this is a funny sort
of irony,
is that in that same year
a robot was released onto the market
by a company called Hanson Robotics,
and the robot was called Pepper.
And robots such as these were being
trained to recognise and I quote,
"62 different facial and neck
architectural features of humans."
So while the robots were learning
62 different ways to recognise us,
and to be able to tell
what emotions we were feeling,
we were being allowed a range
of six emotions on social media.
I'm sure you've noticed this too,
that on social media
we're asked to experience
two completely different kinds
of emotions one after the other.
So on your timeline you may see
that your best friend's child
is sort of toddling around
on the carpet.
You may feel the warmth
and excitement of that.
And then the next post
could be something about
7,000 killed in an earthquake.
The way that the timeline
and the news feeds are structured
really have no emotional
consistency at all.
So we're often being jerked
in our effective responses
from one emotion
to the next quite quickly.
And I think this century
will be about how do we cope
with these quick gear changes
in our emotional lives.
Where people's internal landscapes
are being altered
very, very radically
from one emotion to the next.
Really the name of the game
in social media commerce
is to make your time on the site
as maximum as possible.
So a lot of the ways
that the websites are designed
to encourage you to stay on it,
to return to it,
and how they do that
is to create quite addictive
little algorithms, such as
there's one where on Twitter
there's a bit of a delay before how
many notifications you have come up.
And there's a very human,
basic response there,
where we wait to see something
that is variable and changing.
We get a little hit of dopamine,
when there's a category of data
that is changing that we can monitor.
So there's that brief moment
of excitement that we all know
even when we're just
checking an email,
"How many new emails do I have?"
"How many notifications?"
And that little pause encourages in
us that sort of sense of anticipation
that is then rewarded
when we see the actual number.
So in this way, social media
is trying to tap in
to very fundamental things about
how our psychologies work
and our emotional lives
are structured.
Thanks for watching!
If you enjoyed that, be sure
to check out these videos next.
And if you haven't already,
hit the subscribe button
and click the bell
to get a notification
each time we upload a new video.